there's a million-in-one ways to solve a
problem and we've always never fell in
love with a particular solution we've
always fell in love with a problem as
strongarm I'm Sean Peterson I'm 26 years
old and I'm the CEO strongarm
Technologies creates the future for the
industrial athlete so that means we use
data and power design in order to create
augmentation equipment that reduces
injury for those industrial athletes
[Music]
Grover Long Island working working in
construction my dad actually passed away
on the job so I went off and I went to
school for product design and
entrepreneurship and I really wanted to
create products that help make people's
lives a little bit less hard like we
said we only create products if we know
that the individuals are gonna really
love it
but the biggest thing is really figuring
out the end of day what the pain and
fatigue levels are are of the
individuals wearing it and we've seen
pain in fatigue dropped by almost half
for the products that we create
throughout the day and that's really
inspiring for us to continue to be able
to drive them that's that's the passion
of I mean the passion is creating
creating that and every time you go back
a little bit more someone likes a little
bit more and you're really creating
value for these people the standard
adjust comes from that inspiration from
them
the biggest risk we've ever taken is we
spent a lot of money that we really
didn't have and the products work when
we sent them out but when they came back
from the prototyper there were some
defects that we didn't know about
consider below the surface and they all
failed we all packed up her bags fully
down to the site fixed everything that
we could on site again really owning up
to the problem solving the solution
committing a lot of personal time and
money to making sure that we did right
by the client ended up leading into a
really big sound
[Music]
Solutions they work once the athletes
tell us we're not going to decide if it
works from our lab data we're not going
to decide if it works from if it's
manufactured and it's pretty and it's
selling we're gonna decide if the people
wearing it don't want to give it back to
you at the end of the day and that's how
we know that we actually have created
something
[Music]